no fui a Rusia y no iré a Ucrania
solo iré cuando haya una posibilidad
real de un clima para la construcción de
la paz nunca iguale a los dos países
porque sé lo que es una invasión y sé
que es la integridad del territorio y
todos pensamos que Rusia cometió un
error
esas fueron las palabras con las que el
presidente de Brasil Luis Ignacio Lula
da Silva pareció dar por concluida la
polémica desatada por sus comentarios
respecto a su posición sobre la Guerra
de Ucrania la semana pasada lanzó un
llamado a Estados Unidos Estados Unidos
Tiene que dejar de fomentar la guerra y
empezar a hablar de paz
sus declaraciones causaron el enfado de
Washington y Ucrania desde la Casa
Blanca acusaron al presidente de repetir
como un loro el discurso de Rusia sobre
el conflicto una reacción que contrastó
con la de Moscú el canciller ruso
sergeilafroff agradeció la postura de
Brasil
en cuanto a los procesos en Ucrania
estamos agradecidos con amigos
brasileños por su excelente comprensión
de la Génesis de esta situación
y estamos agradecidos por su deseo de
contribuir a la búsqueda de formas de
resolverla
Lula se encuentra en una encrucijada
parece estar sobre una cuerda floja en
la que se juega su objetivo de liderar
un proceso de mediación entre ambas
partes del conflicto que hace poco que
está Lula en el poder cien días y creo
que a veces este los líderes no miden el
digamos quiere repetir vieja fórmulas o
no No miden el el impacto de sus
palabras como ya le digo Este es un
periodo que es poco permisivo a a tener
posturas muy muy este
zigzagueantes Lula deberá saber escoger
bien sus cartas para dejar de ser
acusado de complaciente con Rusia y a la
vez no alejarse del kremlin para
conseguir impulsar un posible plan de
paz